Далекобійником до Європи. Європейські країни полюють на водіїв з України.
Найбільше шукає Польща, Великобританія, Німеччина та країни Балтії.
Наші водії дійсно вміють працювати, хочуть працювати. А попит є, бо дійсно
не вистачає водіїв у Польщі, ФРН, Англії. До речі, і балтійські країни побоюються,
що не буде вистачати. Вони і так - що прибалти, що поляки…
Їхня транспортна галузь виїжджає на українцях та білорусах. Це дійсно так.
Ярослав Клименко знає це з власного досвіду, адже вже 5 років працює водієм в Польщі.
Каже, затятим далекобійником став у 2015-тому. До того працював водієм автобусів в Україні.
Проте сімейні обставини змусили його шукати більш гідну зарплатню.
Поїхав до Польщі, отримав польські документи на право керування вантажівкою,
там же пройшов навчання і працевлаштувався в польську фірму.
Сам, без усіляких посередників. Оплатою, умовами праці та ставлення до працівників
Ярослав дуже задоволений.
Є тахограф. Дуже гарна річ. У Європі суворо дотримуються режиму праці та відпочинку.
У нас в Україні є прилади, які можна відключити. Є водії, які вставляють два чипи
і їздять по-чорному, як-то кажуть. І так само дуже важливий момент,
чому я працюю не на українську, а саме на європейську фірму в Польщі
- це дотримання умов праці та відпочинку водіїв.
Відпрацював 9 годин, стаєш на паузу. А в Україні з точки А в точку Б поїхав і без дотримання.
У Польщі нині не вистачає близько ста тисяч 100 000 водіїв.
Польські водії виїжджають на заробітки у Німеччину, Францію, Великобританію,
де оплата праці ще вища. Останніми тижнями світові ЗМІ облетіли кадри,
як на тлі брекзіту і карантинних обмежень британська економіка мало не зупинилася
через гостру нестачу далекобійників. Адже більшість з них були трудовими мігрантами,
зокрема з тієї ж Польщі, а тепер виїхали з країни або через брекзіт, або через пандемію.
Відсутність регулярних поставок у Великобританії призвела до шалених черг на заправках,
а в магазинах спорожніли полиці. Аби зарадити проблемі, уряд оголосив,
що видасть 5 тисяч тимчасових віз усім, хто готовий сісти за кермо.
Німецькі перевізники також б'ють на сполох: тут уже нині бракує 80 тисяч водіїв вантажівок.
Як вважає представник великої Фейсбук-спільноти "Далекобійники UA" Дмитро Левченко,
причини такого дефіциту робочої сили не лише у відтоку трудових мігрантів
через пандемію, а й тому, що в Європі загалом катастрофічно зростає
брак робочих рук. Його, власне, хочуть покрити за рахунок охочих з України.
Український водій - як універсальний солдат. Він може зробити колесо на ходу,
зупинитися, сам поміняти балку, мало не перебрати двигун.
Всі знають, що він доїде, куди треба - хоч на одному колесі, але доїде.
Тому через ці якості Європа і країни Балтії обирають українських водіїв.
У Львові вже навіть є спеціальна школа далекобійників.
Тут навчають водіїв за європейськими стандартами, працюють курси підвищення кваліфікації.
Заснувала школу фірма, яка спеціалізується на пошуку персоналу
для європейських автомобільних компаній. Тут кажуть, що останнім часом
з Польщі дійсно побільшало запитів на водіїв з України. Але додають,
що це загалом не нове явище, бо попит на українських далекобійників
є стабільним уже впродовж останніх 5 років. Просто нині країни Європи
спрощують правила працевлаштування для працівників з країн - не членів ЄС.
Завжди був попит. На даний момент просто через брак людей,
кваліфікованої кадрової сили багацько компаній знизили поріг входження на їхній ринок, скажімо так.
Колись водій, який іде туди на роботу, повинен був не тільки вміти
керувати транспортним засобом, але й розбиратися в режимі праці та відпочинку,
вміти кріпити спеціалізовані вантажі. Я вже не кажу про такі речі, як правила дорожнього руху.
Нині все спрощено. Багацько крупних логістичних компаній створюють центри профосвіти.
Наприклад, компанія займається перевезенням продуктів. І ось вони взяли і від А  до Я навчили людину.
Брак кадрів змушує країни Євросоюзу змінювати свою політику на ринку праці.
У тій же Польщі зустріти в установах, у транспортних компаніях фахівців,
які можуть говорити українською, вже давно не проблема. Польща, Німеччина,
а тепер і Великобританія напрацьовують спеціальні схеми, аби мати юридичні підстави
приймати далекобійників з інших країн на навчання, перепідготовку, на роботу,
укладати з ними договори різних термінів, брати на роботу фахівців-початківців.
Людина в Україні, приміром, працювала охоронцем, далі пішла навчатися
на водія на півроку. Йому оплачують це і вже чекають на нього в Польщі.
Для нього місце вже закріплено. Його завдання - отримати водійські права.
Після чого його в Польщі довчають за їхніми правилами. Він спочатку їздить з партнером у тандемі,
і місяців через три його відпускають у вільне плавання. У Польщі в принципі
один і той самий маршрут. І той, хто не дурний, швидко починає працювати та заробляти.
Раніше знайти роботу в Європі було набагато складніше - це підтверджує і Ярослав Клименко.
Наприклад, на одній фірмі я, коли ще не мав досвіду роботи в Європі,
намагався влаштуватися. Мені сказали, що, мовляв, ні, потрібні робітники з досвідом.
А зараз, я так дивлюся, що беруть вони навіть без досвіду. Реально смішно.
П’ять років тому, коли немає досвіду, то ні - до побачення, телебачення.
А зараз немає досвіду - давай, бери машину, сідай та їдь.
Ярослав переконаний, що це може погано відобразитися на безпеці руху в самій Європі.
Він згадує випадки, коли його колеги дозволяли собі вживати алкоголь до виїзду,
ба навіть під час рейсу. ДТП за участю водіїв-далекобійників з інших країн,
зокрема і з України, на дорогах ЄС траплялися не раз. Ярослав каже, що
добре "муштрують" водіїв у Європі високі штрафи, які привчають далекобійників
чітко дотримуватися усіх європейських правил, не лише на дорогах.
Адже платить їх водій з власної кишені. Крім того, радить Ярослав,
слід уважно вивчити договір з роботодавцем, аби потім не влетіти в копієчку.
Обіцяють зарплату - 70 євро на добу. Приїжджаєш туди - працевлаштовуєшся.
А кажуть, що 70 євро буде, якщо ти мінімум 3 місяці будеш працювати.
Потім, що, мовляв, у тебе зависокі витрати пального! Мало бути 30 літрів, а в тебе 31.
Усе - в тебе вдвічі менша запрала. Такі нюанси. І можуть змушувати
не дотримуватися режиму праці та відпочинку.
Спочатку гарно-гарно все розповідають, а потім не знаєш, як куди подітися.
Високий попит на досвідчених далекобійників з України зробив їх перебірливими, кажуть експерти.
Він не буде розмінюватиcя на договір на півроку-рік.
Йому потрібен більш серйозний термін. І тому ті квоти, які, приміром, виділяє Британія на півроку,
їм уже не підходять, такими плюшками водія не заохотити.
Вони обирають, приміром, пропозицію, що якщо пропрацюєш рік,
то отримаєш карту поляка на дружину, на дітей. Тоді він з радістю поїде
і навіть інші варіанти розглядати не буде.
Не лише кращий заробіток спонукає українських водіїв виїжджати за кордон.
Розбиті дороги і відсутність придорожньої інфраструктури в Україні теж.
Ох ти! Йолки-палки, ліс густий! Єть!! Я скільки себе пам’ятаю, тут яма є.
Латають-латають… Роблять дороги. Чому не зробить паркінги для фур?
У нас дуже багато машин. Я не кажу про такі, як у Польщі.  Там є туалет безкоштовний,
душ безкоштовний. Просто хоча б місце зробити, щоб машин ставити.
І по факту водії встають просто вдовж узбіч, і дуже часто аварії, в’їжджають в автомобілі.
Крім того, нових фур, на яких працювати комфортніше, в Україні менше, ніж старих.
Роботодавці часто відмовляються підвищувати зарплатню, змушують водіїв
за свій рахунок ремонтувати фуру в дорозі тощо.
Ті, хто працює в Україні, рано чи пізно зрозуміють, що поїхавши до Польщі,
мене не буде місяць, але я принесу 50-60 тисяч гривень. То люди будуть тікати з України.
Це парадоксально. Це про оплату. А про умови праці і про наші дороги,
про Укртрансбезпеку, котра себе веде дуже негарно, то будуть тікати.
У нас незабаром, думаю, так само будуть проблеми з водіями.
Усе це призводить до того, що в самій Україні вже також існує брак водіїв, кажуть експерти.
За різними даними, 10% автопарку великих компаній простоюють
через нестачу робочих рук. Ярослав сподівається, що українські перевізники
замисляться над цим і почнуть краще дбати про своїх працівників.
Аби вони і в Україні могли працювали за європейськими стандартами.
Інакше, каже Ярослав, одного дня перебої з поставками бензину
та порожні полиці супермаркетів, як це було у Великобританії,
з'являться і в Україні.